all right ladies and gentlemen I think
we're going to start hi I'm Margaret
Warner and you know our distinguished
panel and I those of you who've been
here part are all of the last two days I
think we've had a just fascinating and
Rich presentation of a lot of aspects of
this religion versus science debate so
what I'm going to try to do in this next
I don't know hour and 15 hour and 20
minutes is to pull it all together and
try to highlight some of the differences
we heard and I I guess um if I'm I'm
successful maybe I'll be like the Divine
watchmaker
and if I'm unsuccessful it'll be like
the blind watchmaker completely random
but with that let's just start
one central question I think that we
heard debated and analyzed was this
essential question of whether one can
believe in God
and an evolution
and if I if I might let me just say as a
layperson here's what I heard I mean if
there's a whole gradation
uh from a Stephen J Gould sort of well
there are separate Realms to the idea
put on the table by Lawrence that well
if you if you believe that there's a God
of all causes then even random selection
could be his cause
um and then Alvin
um
planting just suggested you didn't call
it this but almost like a thumb on the
scale that God could set these processes
in motion but he could also kind of wait
how things might turn out or that that
are that a mutation might occur or at
least be kept alive long enough to take
root and uh and then you could perhaps
go to the Francis Collins model which I
I think can discussed that
um God set up
Evolution and natural selection though
as I've read him what he's saying is
with the aim of actually ultimately
producing a human-like being with whom
God could actually communicate a human
being that needed God that needed that
had Consciousness that had intellectual
capacity conceptual understanding so and
Ken I'd like to start with you as as one
of the scientists here
if if there is a search for harmonizing
these views which Ron also described in
his um that there have been attempts at
this before where could there be a
convergence and still be true to science
well I think um
Ron's talk was to me especially early on
was litany
of all the people who had tried to work
for peace and Harmony had gotten chewed
up and spit out
and I was I was wondering what fate he
would predict for me give it give her
those circumstances but
um I think essentially
the starting point
um is actually pretty simple and the
starting point is first of all to
respect reason
um the the Western
religious tradition the abrahamic
tradition
views faith and reason both as gifts
from God and we look into the founding
of science we look into the history of
Science in the west and we see that the
scientific Enterprise actually comes out
of the abrahamic tradition of studying
nature through rational means to the
greater glory of God now you don't have
to be a person of Faith to appreciate
the fact that this
reverence for rationality if you will is
built into the Western mind and comes
out of the western conception of
religion and to appreciate and to
respect that and I think the first thing
that is incumbent upon religious people
to do is basically to respect reason and
and and ultimately science is reason and
rationality practically apply what's
incumbent upon this the people in the
scientific tradition to do is to
recognize recognize that Western
rationality comes out of Western
religious thought and even if they
themselves reject a personal God or a
spiritual life or any other sort of God
to reflect the fact that this tradition
of reason is bound into basically the
Western religious tradition and
therefore that attempts to understand
religion and science as being
complementary are very very much in the
historic tradition of Science and to be
respected and to some extent to be
appreciated if not always to be agreed
with let me yeah actually let me first
go to to Alvin plantago do you see an
opening there and if so is it in a sort
of reverence do you see do you see an
opening there and so do you think it's
where Ken Miller sees it
um well I I agree very much with what
Ken just said now and also very much
with what he said of what he said with
what he said in his lecture which kind
of surprised me I'd never met him before
and although I'd heard these distant
Rumblings about Ken Miller and what he
said about the ideas and the like of
that I didn't really know what he
thought so I was pleasantly surprised
there and I agree with him on this last
point and I would carry it further
really it's not I would say just that
science grew out of the Matrix was
conceived and born out of the womb of
Christian belief I'm inclined to think
that science can't really seriously be
seriously sustained without some similar
kinds of beliefs I don't think science
fits it all well with naturalism the
idea that there isn't any such person as
God or anything like God I mean science
grew out of the Matrix of Christian
belief in two separate ways first of all
according to Christian belief God
created The World God is a person an
intelligent person and created it in a
rational reasonable sensible way and
secondly he created human beings in His
image
an important part of which is they're
being able to to know the world and to
know something about themselves and to
know something about God himself and
science is just a sort of prime
extremely glittering important example
of that
so uh so I would like to uh I'd like to
see Ken on this point and raise him one
Ron
I just wanted to to say it's a popular
and pleasant Christian conceit that
Western rationality and science came out
of the ibrahamic or maybe the the
Christian tradition even but aren't we
uh sort of marginalizing uh what the
Greeks did who weren't Christians or
children of Abraham no I no I I don't
think so and and boy Lawrence can
appreciate this boy am I scared I'm now
talking about the origin science I'm
between a historian and a philosopher
and for Natural Science this is a
terrifying position to be in
um but I think what one has to look at
in terms of Western Intel Western
religious and intellectual life are the
various attempts that especially
Christian theologians made to harmonize
Greek philosophy and Greek understanding
I mean the great project of Thomas
Aquinas was basically to take the works
of Aristotle and Plato and christianize
them in one sense or another to use
Greek rationality as the ultimate basis
for Christian and belief and I would I
would argue and I'm not a historian so
I'm certainly subject to being slapped
down by the historians in the room but I
would argue that the reason that science
as we know it developed in the west and
not in the East where you had
civilizations that in many ways were
much more technologically advanced than
Western Europe in the Middle Ages was
because of the abrahamic view of man
seeing man as something apart from
nature in other words the ability to
step outside of Nature and try to look
at it as an objective Observer is very
much in the western intellectual
tradition the abrahamic tradition the
Eastern tradition as I understand it
always views man as entangled with
nature as part of it and therefore even
the idea of a setting up an experiment
which you can try to observe objectively
it doesn't doesn't emerge out of these
so I I sort of Stand by that point until
as I say I'm slapped down by a historian
who knows this but he'll defend the
proposition that the Greeks were not
rational no I will defend the the
proposition that Western abrahamic
thought merged with the intellectual
traditions of the Greek to the extent
that Western thought was able to do that
um and and fused into a system of
rational thought in which science became
possible right we saw other people dying
to jump in here alone let me if he's not
going to slap you down let me slap you
down Ken
um
for two things he said first of all it's
nice to talk about historical tradition
but the great thing about science is
kind of a historical and and you know it
may have it may have um sorry about that
Ron but uh I mean that that the point is
to understand the science you don't have
to understand the history it's very it's
very Illuminating but it but you don't
need to but the point about history is
one moves Beyond I mean the the other
tradition of the the the theological
tradition of Christianity might have
been ancient Egypt and their son God but
but you don't think you don't say boy
I'm really happy that um that we have
that as a basis for modern Christianity
and the point is that many scientists
would say that well that while your
argument may be may be historically
correct and I think they're key
historical issues is what you said it's
irrelevant that science has in fact
taken us Beyond religion and in fact uh
the the line that I use from Steve
Weinberg I think is really important
that's and infected so I completely
disagree with what you just said album
that that that that science in some
sense needs religion science and I think
it's the the most important thing about
science is that it makes it possible to
not believe in God that it it that it
means if you wish that you can you can
that not everything in life is
miraculous that actually effects have
real causes that you can understand and
if you uh it it what the the real
compatibility between science and
religion it seems to me is ultimately
maybe uh the one that we talked about
for the Catholic church that you just
mentioned the cause of all causes the
the sense of making
God completely invisible and therefore
completely scientifically irrelevant and
therefore the only compatibility I can
see is when God becomes completely
scientifically irrelevant so that
scientists have nothing to say about God
other than their own metaphysical uh uh
predilections and that and that the
natural world they can study without
being a threat to those people who who
believe fundamentally that there's
design and purpose to the world but uh
that uh that God isn't required to to
Tinker it all because in fact there's no
evidence that he's tinkering or she's
tinkering forgive me
to take issue a little bit with the idea
that reason may be the primary basis or
or for common ground between religion
and science because although one can
certainly make that argument and see it
in in the case of a lot of scientists
and then the attempts at least by
intelligent design people to bring
reason into the picture
what I sense and remember I'm the
sociologist here so my world is pretty
much the Grassroots World kind of
talking to people you know Kansas Ohio
places like that what I see is more of
us have a sense of convergence is an
aesthetic appreciation I it was
interesting Ken that you said that
people appreciate reason that suggests
to me that there is an aesthetic
evaluation of what's happening with
knowledge of different kinds where the
reason involved may be quite different
but as I hear people on the religious
side who are trying to come to terms
with okay how shall we understand
science they're often saying well I'm
really impressed by the mystery of it
all or by the awe of nature or by Wonder
and then what they find on the science
side that kind of says to them you know
we can get along with these people are
some of the same things when Francis
Collins talks and writes that's often
the language he uses and when other
scientists talk about Insight or
intuition as part of the scientific
process then I notice again that a lot
of people relate to that so it may be
that we're
ironically moving beyond some of the
faith and reason at least that
characterized the enlightenment or at
least faith in rationalism to something
that's tempering reason a little bit at
least
what about the theory and I'll take
whoever would like to to speak on this
some physicists have suggested it's
called The Theory of Everything That
science and religion actually coalesce
in the structure of the universe and I
think Stephen Hawking and Brief History
of Time sort of touches on this and that
you mentioned Francis Collins that when
he went to the White House in 2000 along
with Craig Venter to announce the first
sort of rough draft mapping of the human
genome he said it is humbling for me and
awe-inspiring to realize we have caught
the first glimpse of our own instruction
book previously known only to God in
other words he was trying to be very
careful to say
that well I should I won't even
paraphrase them I'll let his word stand
but it almost seems to be going back to
the I don't know 14th 15th century idea
that that in the judeo-christian and
correct me if I'm wrong Ron here but
that God had created the world according
to some sort of divine mathematical plan
or divine plan which might be called the
laws of nature and that to try to
understand that plan was to try to
decipher the mind of God and that
therefore there wasn't a conflict and I
I'm just wondering does this Theory of
Everything are we moving back to that
well actually I think we're as a
physicist I want to clarify one thing
and some almost moving away from that
and in a sense that many people would
find dangerous the the long tradition of
Science and and is that the sense that
the the universe had to be the way it is
there's only one possible set of
physical laws that hang together that
produce a workable universe and our job
was kind of discover them and that's
certainly what what Einstein meant when
he unfortunately often used the term God
because he certainly didn't believe in
the kind of God that a personal a God
that had any personal interest in human
in human Affairs but and and so I think
scientists inevitably have that kind of
basic belief if you want to call it that
that there is some rational there are
rational rules that govern the world and
that if we had a theory of everything we
would understand why the universe is the
way it is interestingly enough
what's happened last year is is the
failure to to get anywhere near that has
led to an opposite perspective that in
fact there may be no rules that govern
the universe fundamentally and and that
our universe is one of perhaps an
infinite number of universes in which
each of one of which has different
physical laws and we just happen to be
an environmental accident that's kind of
the ultimate form of evolution if you
wish because it says why are we living
in this universe because life can live
in this universe we'd be living in
Another Universe except life can't live
in that one it's you know why bees like
honey and Etc it's it's it's it's sort
of almost in the extreme version of
evolution in the cosmic sense but it
would say in some sense that there's
there's not not even any fundamental
rational framework that explains why our
universe is the way it is it's just an
accident
but but there's a there's a really
interesting
um corollary way to look at what
Lawrence just brought up and what he
referred to is generally known as the
multiple Universe hypothesis for example
there's a wonderful book I believe it's
by Martin Reese the astronomer Royal
called just six numbers and Rhys talks
about six numbers many of which are
racist so I think he's kind of cheating
because he's using two numbers in the
ratio where he talks about fundamental
constants of Nature and if any of them
were just a little bit different we
probably wouldn't be here so he says
these six numbers now he's not a theist
but he points out that the Universe
really depends upon this Coincidence of
physical constant so one way to look at
this is he admits is to say well you
could interpret that by saying that
there was a Creator who set these things
up so that we could be here but then
there's another way to look at it which
Lawrence just pointed out which is
we're alive we're all here today so duh
of course we live in a universe that
makes life possible because if this
universe didn't make life possible
there'd be no Terry lectures and there'd
be nobody here to talk about it so
that's the other side of the coin but
the Curious theological leap that has
always struck me about the multiple
Universe hypothesis is that many people
um who are agnostic or atheists
criticize anyone in science for being a
theist by saying you know you've reduced
God to the point where there's
absolutely no evidence there's nothing
testable he's become as learned to said
invisible well you know the Curious
Thing about the multiple Universe
hypothesis is that all those parallel
universes by definition you can't
communicate with them you can't test
them you can't have evidence for them
either so they've become invisible so
there is a quasi-theological element to
that argument I think many people in
science find very disturbing yeah it
does concern some of us yeah well I want
to jump in at some previous Point here
with respect to I wanted to comment
um briefly on something Ken said early
on about reason I mean um it is true it
seems to me that science that science
presupposes two things that the universe
is in some sense reasonable rational has
a certain structure even if it's a
Multiverse there is still a certain kind
of structure in each of the multi in
each of the sub universes and for the
whole Multiverse too there's a certain
kind of structure there's got to be a
something that generates these different
multi multi universes in the whole
Multiverse and the like but one
interesting thing about modern Western
science as opposed to the Greeks and
this is addressed to something Ron said
is that modern Western science is
heavily empirical
uh perception counts for a great deal
empirical perception much more so than
for the Greeks for the Greek science was
much more apriori that is much more a
matter of figuring things out without
actually taking a look but just being
able to think them through think them
out now one Christ important Christian
doctrine is the doctrine of creation
According to which God created the world
and was free not to he wasn't obliged to
so it's not a necessary truth that he
created the world and given that he
created it it's not a necessary truth
that he created it the way it's been
created it could have been many other
ways and the way and that means that if
it's not a necessary truth that it's
this way it's a contingent truth and the
contingent is the realm of um what we
philosophers laughingly call a
posteriori thought that is not a priori
not prior to perception but involving
perception you have to go out and take a
look you can't as some of the
Aristotelian medieval uh Aristotelian
scientists were accused of not wanting
they wanted to know how many teeth a
horse had in its mouth they didn't want
to look they wanted to try to deduce it
from first principles that's the sort of
Greek approach whereas the Christian
approach would be to say well God could
have done it any number of ways let's go
let's see how we did do it
I wanted to look at questions about well
first of all I think these are questions
that science Natural Science doesn't
answer for us and I there seem to be
General agreement that science does not
explain the meaning of life or whether
there's meaning to life or or why are we
here but it seemed to me again as a
layperson that maybe all of you were
saying well things in the Physical Realm
are explained
by science or or remain to be explained
by science
my question is has science ever
explained or or proven that how
intelligent life might evolve from
unintelligent life unconscious life
yeah natural selection I think it's
called
um you do yeah I think I mean it
certainly what depends what you mean by
proven you even is the wrong one no no
it's very important that we get this
clear here I tried to say it the other
day but I want to re-emphasize here
science doesn't prove things to be right
it that's a big misconception it can
never prove anything to be right it can
only prove things to be wrong that's its
great strength so it if you sh what what
you can show is that something doesn't
work if it works you don't know if it's
true you just know it's not false and so
uh what what natural selection is
provided uh via evolution is a mechanism
that plausibly and in fact predictably
explains the diversity of all life that
we've observed on Earth including human
life and including
um uh intelligent life now do we
understand all the detailed mechanisms
absolutely not but the keep one of the
big fallacies in this big debate with
evil with a lot of the ID people is that
just just because you don't understand
something doesn't mean you don't
understand anything and and and so
there's a lot we don't understand and
that's why we like to do science but but
you know because we don't understand not
because we understand so I think natural
selection has provided a perfectly
plausible mechanism that also satisfies
every experimental test that we've ever
performed and therefore at this point
there's no reason to to expect that it
won't be able to explain the evolution
of intelligence but Bob or Ron is that
where much of the public and we we heard
some some interesting polling numbers
from Bob early on that's the choke point
for much of the public that they might
accept that uh you know fish could grow
into a land mammal but it's it's the
creation of or the evolution or whatever
verb you want to use the emergence of
what we consider human qualities of
of awareness self-awareness sense of
right and wrong is that where the the
problem is yeah for for a lot of the
public the issue is okay however we got
here and you know frankly a lot of the
public really doesn't care and that may
be one reason why we have these these
debates because they're easily persuaded
by whoever you know comes along but
they'll say okay now that we're here and
we clearly have Consciousness and
therefore some things that seem to go
along with Consciousness thought culture
the Arts morality and so forth
and presumably again we're trying to be
kind of speciesist and so we want to be
different from other species so we we as
humans assume that other species don't
have Consciousness or at least assume if
they do
then it's different somehow from from
ours and so we do a great deal to kind
of try to figure out what that means the
more thoughtful of us will say well does
that in any way change the Dynamics of
natural selection that we can think and
choose and destroy ourselves or not
destroy ourselves save ourselves invent
things and so forth or others will say
well you know this is this is just
something that happened in a long long
series of evolution and it will continue
to happen and so maybe what we think now
is the high point is just the fact that
we happen to be able to think about it
whereas you know later other species or
whatever comes afterwards will view
things if they view things at all in a
very different way now I think where
where it really hits home to a lot of
the public is when they think about when
we think about our own existence
so yes how we came into being is one of
the questions but where we're headed
especially as individuals is the big
question
we're going to die
we know that and you know religion for
centuries has provided all sorts of
answers we're going to go to heaven and
we're going to live with God and we're
going to sing and we're going to be with
angels and we're going to see our
relatives who have passed on before us
I think if we really wanted to stir up
big conflict between religion and
science all we'd have to do is have you
know the scientific Community come out
strongly and say when you're dead you're
dead that's it there's nothing else and
think about it absorb it but I'm not
sure that in the in the American public
over 70 percent of the public believes
in life after death and that number has
actually increased over the last several
decades yeah the debate has been very
much or the search for common ground
about the God the Creator role but
there's the god the Redeemer and I mean
is science is that a frontier that
science is going to address
well I I uh let me jump you're trying to
address as a biologist and confirm that
biologically when you're dead you're
dead scientist said that for a long time
I mean please come on
um and and and and no one in science to
my knowledge has ever expressed the
competence of science to talk about the
reality or the unreality of a spiritual
life after death so I think everybody
knows
um whether they're Believers or not that
this is not something that science is
going to tell us about science is not
gonna say something about that I'm sure
Carl Sagan did but I remember being old
enough to remember that when Yuri
Gagarin the first man to orbit the Earth
orbit the earth they asked him what did
you see up there and he said I didn't
see no Angels
um and what he was talking about is the
very naive belief that religious people
believe that God's standing on top of a
cloud somewhere but science can do I
mean but you know as well as I you could
at least you can search for positive
evidence and and find a lack of you know
the men any experiments looking to the
way people when they die to see if the
if the spirit was in any way I mean so
so there are questions that people can
ask and have asked and so again as I
said earlier the lack of evidence you
know absence of evidence isn't evidence
of apps oh that's that's exactly right
but please don't forget to apply that to
religion as much as we do to science Ron
I just wanted to go back to your earlier
uh question about what people believe
and what bothers them I think you're
you're right about the origin of life
and I think that that in terms of
attitudes toward Evolution they're
rather surprising
the stricter you are as a creationist
the more Evolution you have to admit
and that's because of the flood among
other things because of Noah's flood you
believe that there was a flood that
eliminated all life on Earth but what
was in there so if you have a six to ten
thousand year old world
uh then you have to have say one pair of
canines
producing in 4 300 years roughly
the foxes the coyotes the domestic dogs
we have they're happy to invoke natural
selection for that they don't have any
objection they call this microevolution
that's not a problem with these people
they have to have Evolution uh on Fast
Forward what really concerns them are
the big breaks uh matter life humans and
the divisions between these these
originally created kinds so
evolutionists are all the time saying oh
we've just discovered this marvelous
empirical evidence of speciation
this will just shut up the creationist
in fact it they need that
they they don't that doesn't bother them
at all so what we think some of these
people are bothered by many of them
aren't bothered
I I'd like to go back also go back to
your question
whether we've got some kind of
explanation in evolution or anywhere
else of the rise of mentality how it is
that there can be creatures who think
and reason and can do physics and can do
evolutionary biology and the like of
that
um I don't I don't think we have any
explanation for that it's not that it's
not that exactly
um Evolution hasn't provided an
explanation for it we just can't see how
it could be as it seems to me how a
piece of matter of some sort of brain
lots of neurons clicking away together
how how that could amount to could be
the same thing as or produce or be such
as to have thought super being on it so
there's this um this three and a half
pounds of brain of meat there clicking
away lots of neurons I don't know how
many there are some 10 to the 11th
neurons and so on they're connected in
various interesting ways in the like how
does that amount to thought how does
that somehow bring it about that I can
experience red how can my experiencing
red just be some kind of brain activity
of that sort seems to me we don't have
any explanation for this you don't we
don't but do you you surely aren't
suggesting we won't we don't have any
explanation for that and I don't think
we ever will either because what we'll
find will be
okay well that's what we'll find will be
correlations we'll find that as we have
found to some degree now that when
somebody thinks a certain thought a
certain part of his brain lights up I
mean there's more electrical activity
there more blood flow to that and so on
but that doesn't show us at all how
these electrons are I mean these neurons
influencing each other electrical
signals going back and forth how that
could somehow engender or just be and
experience an experience of red or
something like that I don't I don't
think we're going to find much by way of
an explanation of that
Alvin I think what done and you've done
it well is to State what I would regard
is the fundamental problem in
Neuroscience which is how does
associative intelligence work how does
the brain work and I don't know of a
single researcher in Neuroscience who is
not motivated by a desire to answer the
questions that you just threw out there
but here's the proposition I want to
throw right back to you here's the
referral right back I have a question do
you think for a moment
that the question of cognition how do
you see red or the question of sensation
how do I know it's called or the
question of thought how do I decide what
I want to say next will not at some
point ultimately be accounted for by the
physics and the chemistry and the cell
biology of the organ we call the brain
well and would you go as could I just
add would you go as far as the
appreciation of beauty of art of Music
don't get me wrong I don't think we're I
don't think there's going to be a paper
in science next week that's going to say
we work out the circuitry of beauty but
what I'm talking about is we are
physical creatures and the brain works
according to the laws as I say of Cell
Biology physics physics and chemistry
and I would be interested in Alvin
telling us as to whether or not he
thinks the ultimate answer is beyond the
material matter of the brain I certainly
think it's within it and I that's what
that's what I certainly think is a
scientist and I think that's what
motivates neuroscience
yeah I'd be uh um this depends entirely
on what one means by explain or account
for
um there there is a very elegant little
creature named C elegans it's a worm and
it's neural circuitry has been
completely mapped so you know you know
exactly which neurons are connected it
doesn't have very many neurons I think
it's maybe got 114 or something like
that but I mean I'm not sure about that
maybe even know just how many it's got
anyway it's been somebody the audience
knows
thank you 124. well I was fairly close
for for a philosopher that wasn't bad
well it wasn't bad even for a scientists
you were correct within an order of
magnitude
right so I mean maybe we could
completely get it I mean it would be an
enormously complex thing to have such a
complete map of the whole human nervous
system but suppose we did and suppose we
knew exactly which neurons did which
when somebody remembered something when
somebody thought seven plus five equals
12 when somebody thought naturalism is
all the rage these days and the like
that wouldn't answer the question I was
asking I don't think we still wouldn't
know okay why is it that way I mean
that why is it these other ones why is
it when they move in this fashion we get
uh we get that thought there just isn't
that kind of connection there it'd be
like we'd have to have a whole a whole
set of you might say root laws of some
sort I I think you've also not
enunciated main question that motivates
neurobiologists but you've also
explained extremely well why Richard
Dawkins has been derided here has said
that many people Many religious people
and this is his statement on mine but I
think you've
Illustrated it seems to me give up
thinking
uh I'm real I'm I don't mean to be I'm
sorry to be so upper door but to give up
the notion that we might that it's just
to suggest a priori that we'll never
understand something that we don't
understand when we don't even know
enough to know whether what it is to
mean understanding but to suggest in
advance that there's no way of
understanding it is just the antithesis
of of Science and it seems to me it's
just a defeatist attitude that that that
is to be scorned and well maybe it's a
score maybe it's a scorned worthy
attitude but it still might be true I'm
not so much worried about being
scientifically correct or or having the
right the right um approved attitudes
I'm just making suggestions I mean if
that's the way it looks that doesn't
mean people shouldn't try of course they
should I I think the other response to
to all of this is that let's suppose we
are in fact able to explain it all with
physics or biology or nerve circuitry or
whatever one of the things that we would
probably find at that point was that we
had a human need to also explain it in
other ways
to go kind of back to the papyrian and
where does that come sure you can reduce
everything down but it may be that part
of human consciousness is that we
actually have some desire for religion
or Transcendence or beauty or whatever
and so once the scientists have told us
exactly how it works we're going to say
yeah but we're still going to keep
thinking about it because there are
other levels that we want to understand
all right another
um
uh
aspect of the physical world or one time
the physical world that I'm wondering if
science has explained and let me start
with Ron on this if is we have evidence
of a big bang what 14 15 billion years
ago and
theory that explains how life evolved
from that but what about before the Big
Bang
well
one minute before the Big Bang only God
exists no I don't have no I oh but this
this is the sort of question that lay
people perpetually bring up well what
happened before the Big Bang well uh I
don't think there's anybody here who's
going to tell us what happened before
the big we have a scientific explanation
but it's a cop-out yeah we say I mean
the current best picture is that there
it's not a good question apparently that
time the time is related to nature of
space and therefore the time itself may
have come into existence let me find my
question to Ron though what and turning
to the sister what I meant is when the
Big Bang Theory came out was this the
reaction
and and what what was the reaction to
the Big Bang Theory yes I mean did
people
well it respond by saying that well
that's that's an interesting question
well I'm good uh excuse me I should have
refined it it it came out as a
competitor to something called the
steady state interpretation of the
universe which bothered a lot of
Christians because it didn't seem to be
really directional so some especially
liberal Christians Embrace The Big Bang
as actually verifying a notion of an
initial creation
conservative Christians tended to pass
it off as just another point in the
larger evolutionary scheme and so they
more more often than not just dismissed
it because they knew the universe wasn't
that old to begin with and it didn't
help them at all and and let me
underline what Ron just said because
I've also had dialogue with conservative
Christians on this issue and the the
first thing they say is explosions
create disorder
the universe is orderly therefore the
Big Bang is nonsense and as Lawrence
pointed out the other day in states
where anti-evolution majorities have
gained control of state boards of
Education I think of Ohio and I think of
also Kansas in addition to going over
after Evolution they also look on earth
science and astronomy and they pull the
big bang out as well so it turns out
that even though many Christians have
looked at that and said ah the universe
had a beginning that is consonant with
our theology from many conservative
Christians they don't like it a bit was
Pious a conservative I mean as I talked
yesterday about the fact how Pope Pius
immediately jumped on it and said
science has proved Genesis they was
thrilled with the big bang I don't think
it was concerned by the standards of
American conservative Christians any
Pope is a liberal okay
Lawrence what
with us now what were you saying about
how science is trying to address that or
decide is science as a scientific
Community not concerned with that
concerned with I know this is a total
layperson's question but sort of put
crudely well what caused the Big Bang
look scientists done that a little
yesterday scientists are as I think many
so the purpose of science is to continue
to ask questions about anything we can
ask questions about and measure let me
let me so of course this I I mean that's
what I get paid for is worrying about
that very question and uh you know
the context of trying to understand the
big bang and trying to if possible
understand if if that's if there is
something before or after or other than
uh but let me just point out something
that's really important this this whole
debate is or not debate so much
discussion has made it seem like this is
a vital issue to scientists and one of
the things you should realize is that
Steve Weinberg who I quoted before and
is strongly an atheist has made it clear
that most scientists don't even think
enough about God to be atheists they
don't think about the issue at all most
scientists don't even I mean issues of
God just never come into it's not under
discussion most people don't most I I
have thought much more about theological
issues in the last four years as I've
tried to defend science against against
uh intelligent design or or attacks on
science than I ever did in my period as
a scientist it just never came up most
scientists don't have any sophisticated
theological Notions they don't worry
about it it's not an issue
so that brings up the question that Bob
put on the table the very first
yesterday
and it it concerns the question of
whether this debate is healthy I think
that many of you the undercurrent seem
to be that it's it's not healthy it's an
assault on science by creationists or
intelligence design people but your view
was it's it isn't happening enough and
that these cases
as extreme and sort of oversimplified as
they are and the media covers them in an
oversimplified way to which I think we'd
all plead guilty that they're actually
healthy because they force us to
confront some really profound questions
about the nature of our existence that
we otherwise wouldn't so I just like to
throw that on the table about is this
debate healthy do we all agree with Ron
that it's it's going to continue
and um you know if so is that a good
thing and is there a way to shape it so
that it's a more productive exercise
well I I guess I want to qualify what
parts of the debate I think might be
good and might be useful to continue and
others that that are not now uh several
of of the folks here have pointed out
quite rightly I think that yeah for
serious Sciences is a big distraction
you know why why should anybody who's
got got the training and the power and
everything to do good science waste
their time on on this stuff now it's
it's wonderful that
you and you and you know several others
around the country have taken the time
to address these you know intelligent
design debates and so forth but in terms
of getting on with science yeah you're
right you know God is is not a big issue
and not even some of these particular
issues that the intelligent design
people have tried to put on the table
probably would be there in the on the
front burner for science
what I do think is valuable is once
again kind of thinking not so much about
the rarified atmosphere in in which
academics live but the the culture the
population at Large
there is so much of a kind of easy
acceptance of every little sound bite
that we're fed by television or that we
see in movies or whatever and so when
people so quickly assume that yep I
believe in creation or Yip I believe in
evolution or yep I believe in both then
we ought to encourage more debate and it
may be that
if there is a silver lining in something
like the Dover Pennsylvania trial it is
that
a debate happened and a judge wrote a
good a good summary and some of you were
saying there may even be a movie coming
out of it that will inform people even
more so that's that's where I and I I
don't believe that just about this
debate between religion and science I
also believe that's one of the good
thing about good things if there is a
good thing at all about the so-called
culture wars or one of the good things
when Democrats and Republicans actually
get together and Duke it out and deepen
the discussion which often doesn't
happen but sometimes those conflicts are
actually good yeah I I I want to uh I'll
be very quick okay I want to say that
that I think this is a moment of great
opportunity you might say it's the best
of times worse the times in catastrophe
Theory you can sometimes reach a point
at which suddenly the the situation will
snap one way or another I think we are I
think the debate is Good from the point
of view that we have a great opportunity
to popularize science to strengthen
understanding of Science and strength
and support for science among the
American people it doesn't have to go
that way that's why I think it's we're
at the Crux but I think ultimately those
of us in the scientific Community like
Lawrence and I have been very outspoken
on this issue see this not just as an
unfortunate distraction from our
laboratory work but is a great
opportunity to increase public
understanding and support for science
sorry well I think it's um
the debate is not only healthy it's
really essential in that I'm inclined to
think the real debate here is not
between religion and science at all but
between naturalism and religion religion
and naturalism these are two basically
very different ways of looking at the
world there really is a deep conflict
there there really is a deep debate
there and science gets kind of co-opted
sometimes by one side sometimes by the
other people like Bennett and Dawkins
try to enlist science in the uh in the
service of naturalism I think totally
mistakenly but they do that on the other
side the creationists
their issues are really religious what
they're really interested in what
they're really against is naturalism and
evolution and so they want to they want
to frame the issue as a scientific issue
when it really isn't that at all it's a
different kind of issue it's a kind of
deep religious issue and it's very
important that this debate continue it's
very important in part because lots and
lots of people's
um I don't know psychological spirit
spiritual health depends on this lots of
Christians around the country and I
happen to be one myself but lots of them
are deeply disturbed by the thought that
maybe science has shown is showing or
has shown or will shown that this is all
a mistake there really uh isn't any such
person as God there isn't any such thing
as Providence there's nothing like that
and it's important that we get really
clear about that does science show that
or not I think science doesn't doesn't
even begin to show that it doesn't even
make any steps in that direction it's
not that kind of a thing at all
it seems to me instead from that point
of view from the Christian Perspective
we should think of science Christians
should think of it as trying to figure
out how God's world works this world
that he's made now how exactly do these
various parts fit together it might very
well be that it's by virtue of some
evolutionary process that or even one
involving natural selection and random
genetic mutation that he created beings
such as us whom he wanted to create if
so fine but the important thing is to is
to see what the what the bearing of
science is on the on these uh two deeply
Divergent ways of looking at the world
uh this is one place where I really
agree with you
in a really important sense I think that
that there are a lot of there are
precisely because there are a lot of
people who fear that science May one day
prove that God doesn't exist they should
understand one of the and and this
relates to what what Ken said there is
an opportunity here to explain what
science is and what it isn't and that's
and both are important it's really
important to explain the limits of
science what science cannot do it's it's
very important to explain to scientists
by the way as much as as much as anyone
else because there is a lot of uber says
as I said earlier physicists are
probably the worst examples of that and
but so there's an opportunity to show
that science has limits to what it can
talk about and that's important for
scientists as well as lay people but at
the same time it's also in the best of
Worlds and I don't think we're in the
best of Worlds is an opportunity to
provide people a chance to think about
science and in Kansas for example for me
one of the great byproducts of that that
those problems and I went to Kansas many
times I'm going again in a few months is
the outgrowth of things such as Kansas
citizens for science where parents got
together and realized you know what this
is an outgrowth what's happening in
Kansas and outgrowth of the fact that
people don't understand science we
should get into our schools and produce
better science curricula so part of the
reaction to this I think it will be to
to do just what you said which is to try
and get people to realize gee we better
do a better job of even if parents have
to get involved in the schools of
teaching science
did you want to jump in right yeah I
have a question I'm a little less
positive than my colleagues here uh I
think we need a lot more discussion and
maybe a little less debate I think that
uh the democratic system is not a good
way to solve these issues and that that
they get polarized unnecessarily I think
they create stereotypes about who's
religious and what Christians believe
what scientists believe or not and I
think it has these debates over over
Evolution have spilled over uh into
debates about stem cell research and
other things and and has
unnecessarily and unproductively
politicized things so I think there's a
real downside to having a Donnie Brook
over science and religion as well as
maybe some of these opportunities and
won't that
become worse I mean stem cell research
genetic manipulation I mean it's the use
to which science is put that a lot of
Americans find threatening or troubling
though I suppose Lawrence as you pointed
out whenever there's a problem then they
want to bring in the scientists to stop
it but it's going to get a lot of
science handle that I mean that's that's
not going to get less threatening to
Believers quote unquote it's going to
get more threatening when you start
talking about playing with the genetics
what we have to do is and this is what
Sciences don't do well enough and it's
one of the reasons you know I'm involved
a lot trying to explain science and is
that the only way it seems to me is to
explain what science is about we have to
do a better job and scientists have in
general up till recently done a
miserable job of explaining what science
is and what we're doing and we have to
do that because if you are bothered by
stem cells now just wait it's going to
get infinitely worse it's going to it's
we're going to be I'm convinced we're
gonna you know in this Century not only
are we going to be creating life out of
out of nothing out of organic materials
but we're gonna it's gonna be worse I
happen to think that probably
within the next Century computers will
become sentient and that we'll have to
address the issue of our biological
future will have to be coupled to to
computers because once they're
self-programmable by there's no way that
biological evolution will be able to
compete and so whether we become Borg or
something else but there these all these
issues are going to become dramatically
in the next in the century are going to
are going to be there and unless we
start preparing people's minds Now by
explaining what what's happening in
science scientists shouldn't be making
the decisions I mean the public in a
democracy the public has to but in it
but in a democracy for it to work the
public has to be informed and and that's
the vital thing we have to not censor
information but do a really good job of
trying to explain things so people can
anticipate what's going to happen and
make rational decisions for society's
good now we've only been talking for 50
minutes and it took a long time for
Lawrence to get Star Trek
but he did
Borg resistance is futile and so forth
so on
um I'm going to disagree with you a
little bit in terms of scientific
prognosis and I'm going to do it not
from the point of view of a physical
scientist from biological scientists I
think
um and stem cell research is going to be
my model my example the the debate about
stem cell research really involves
embryonic stem cell research really
regards regards to the status of the
human embryo in other words what sort of
status of personhood do we assign to the
embryo and many people who would put
themselves in the pro-life Camp because
they regard the human embryo sacrosync
therefore oppose embryonic stem cell
research but I think the interesting
thing about this and a number of people
have worked on this they worked on this
very hard uh good one good example is
William hurl but who's an ethicist of
biology at Stanford University and bill
has worked very hard to try to find a
technological and an ethical end run
around the objections to stem cell
research now we have the first hints of
that actually showing up in actual
experimentation and I remember sitting
down no kidding with a couple of Bishops
and talking to them about the issue of
stem cell research and I pointed out
that every eight weeks somebody sticks a
needle in my arm and they take blood
cells cells out of my body in order to
do research with them or isolate
clotting factors or give them a
transfusion to somebody else got any
moral objections to that the answer is
of course not it's a good thing you're
doing a public service well okay
um I then explained to the Bishops what
about blastocyst was when I explained a
blastocyst this is an early stage in all
mammalian embryonic development which
you have an envelope of cells most of
which will become extra embryonic
membranes not part of a person and then
a little cluster of cells known as the
Inner Cell Mass this is the cluster that
will actually become the person or the
embryo and we knew years ago from
experiments on mice that you could open
the blastocyst tease out a cell
grow that in a Petri dish that's an
embryonic stem cell by the way seal up
the blastocyst throw it back into a
uterus and you know what you get a
perfectly healthy happy Mouse how is
that morally different
from me donating a cell at the Rhode
Island blood center as opposed to
anything else it hasn't destroyed the
individual well they had
they reacted to that in a rather
positive way because they realized that
the people who are promoting embryonic
stem cell research are not mad
scientists or Monsters but rather they
want to to uh to Advocate the moral good
of a alleviating human pain disease and
suffering but they still worried and I
think they're right too about the status
of the embryo left behind and one of
them has to be a really tough question
they said that's fine suppose you and
your wife were trying to conceive by in
vitro fertilization and that blastocyst
was the one that was going to be
implanted into your wife to become your
son or daughter would you allow somebody
to go in with a needle and poke around
and I thought I don't think so and he
said that's exactly the point but I'm
really quite optimistic that in a very
short period of time because of the rate
at which we are understanding the
developmental signals that govern
cellular differentiation that the need
to to basically swipe a couple cells
from the embryo that have learned tricks
that we can't yet understand and use
those for stem cell 30s I think
eventually that's going to become
unnecessary and it will become
unnecessary because we will understand
more of Developmental biology so I'm
optimistic that science is going to
solve technologically some of these
moral dilemmas uh in addition to
foisting new ones on us let me just
throw one other thought and then we'll
go to questions Ron somebody said in a
question today that was here we've all
talked about what science needs to do to
better inform the public but what
science is but what about theology I
mean and as one questioner said you know
most people their their knowledge of
theological Christian thinking or
whatever kind of thinking it is is sort
of Frozen whenever they left Sunday
school at age 12 and that because we
don't teach religion in the schools
which we don't that there's not even
teaching of comparative religions or the
evolution of religious thought in in one
Faith or another
is it as a historical matter is our is
the level of public understanding of
religion less than it was say a hundred
years ago or in the 20s or other times
where this debate was roiling and do you
think that's a problem
you're asking me yeah I think so I uh
just in in my years of teaching I think
uh familiarity with the Bible for
example is has gone down to the point of
almost non-existence uh these days uh I
don't want to unnecessarily offend any
theologians here but occasionally I dip
into the Theology of this subject it's
not going to help anybody uh the
theology dealing with science and
religion today with few exceptions Jack
hot big one of the major ones I think
is so esoteric and so removed from the
interests of any normal person
uh that uh
being theologically ignorant is not
necessarily a big handicap
Alvin I have to go to you on this
oh well I think that's a little a little
strong maybe a little over the top as
long as they're sophisticated
philosophically I meant
I think there are writers um who think
about this and whose work is not all
that unduly complicated hard to follow
John polkinghorn to be one example
and it seems to me it's all it but it
seems Iran is right that the level of
sort of theological or maybe theological
isn't the right word of sort of uh
religious competence or literacy is also
very low I mean people have been
complaining about scientific illiteracy
I think there is uh also a very low
level of religious literacy among uh say
entering college students at the
University of Notre Dame where I teach
many students display uh and almost
appalling and in fact extremely
impressive lack of knowledge of the
Catholic Catholic theology Catholic
Doctrine Catholic tradition they know
next to nothing about it except that
Notre Dame is a Catholic University with
a Dandy football team so so I think that
that's a real problem I think as I was
saying early on I thought
I thought it's important that these
issues be discussed I don't mean debated
but discussed and that Christians come
first of all to learn
exactly what it is the where their
interests as Christians lie just what it
is they actually do believe in how that
fits in with various other parts of the
world very in particular with science I
think that's um one of the main
desiderata and I don't know where this
education is really going to come from
it's not going to come in public schools
maybe students who go to private schools
Catholic schools and also Protestant
schools are have a somewhat better
chance along these lines but even there
in Catholic schools from which many
Notre Dame students come
seems to be there's an absolutely
appalling lack of knowledge of the whole
thing well I think there's let me just
take the other side I know you want to
go to questions but let me just say if
people think they want to ask questions
why don't you go ahead and go to the
mics I think there is an appalling lack
of literacy generally but but I think
the people are it to be you know I know
there's this thing that somehow the
Christians are under attack in our
society today and I just think it's just
nonsense uh I think you know we we in
particular and I'm not Christian
it's everywhere it but it's everywhere
you can't help but be bombarded by and
it's pretty non-sophisticated theology
I'll give you that there's no doubt
about it it's it's the it's the real
world view of you know by real world I
mean the TV show uh level of of of
theology but it's everywhere from the
president United States to everywhere
you're bombarded with Notions of God and
the Christian worldview and so it may
not be sophisticated but I think it's um
it's uh to say that it's disappearing is
is not correct
all right we're going to go to questions
put them right here and if again um if
you would please state your name and uh
affiliation thanks Mary Evelyn Tucker at
the institution for social and policy
studies but I'm also a historian of the
religions of East Asia and the
intellectual history of East Asia and a
long-term interest in this topic so I
thank you very much for your
presentations
um I would just like to invite into the
discussion and it's been part of the
background clearly
um even though we've been focusing
mostly on the U.S for obvious reasons
but a little bit of pluralism might
liven up this discussion and certain
distinctions especially about science
about religion and about Christianity in
particular and I would just invite us uh
Ken said just a few minutes ago that
there was no science outside of the West
and I think we all know no I didn't say
that okay no experimental science no I
said experimental science became
developed in the west yes okay
I do think though for a larger sense of
the background of this discussion
Needham's work on China on science and
technology in China would be hugely of
interest and as a number of you have
said this is not a problem certainly in
East Asia and many parts of the world
the way science has been accepted and
developed and I think that would be of
is significant agriculture irrigation
systems Urban Development medicine and
so on so I just wanted to put that into
the discussion I don't think we we would
probably not disagree with that but as
far as religion goes when Alvin said in
his talk that religion is dealing with
um contact with the supernatural again I
would invite us simply to have some
pluralism here Confucianism has no
interest in in the Supernatural so to
speak nor does Buddhism and I think
these are religions that also need to be
part of of our thinking and in fact
the majority of the world's religions
are not involved with exclusive claims
to truth this only rests within certain
forms of the western Traditions I think
this changes the nature of the
discussion and finally I think when we
come to Christianity
um I think what's unfortunate that it's
not been part of the discussion is that
Christianity is identified with Alvin's
talk with theism that immediately
implies design I don't think is
descriptive of some of the most
interesting thoughtful Reflections in
Christianity that are coming out of
process philosophy and process theology
resting on Whitehead or hot is resting
on tayard and so on but I think what's
particularly interesting and exciting to
to enter into the discussion it gives us
perhaps some of the most fertile grounds
for actually suggesting that creativity
is within the processes of evolution not
something entering from outside and that
the notion of emergence in these
processes that people like Terry deacon
at Berkeley are dealing with give us
some grounds for what Gordon Kaufman the
Theologian at the Divinity School at
Harvard would call serendipitous
creativity that their self-organization
uh creativity but there's also
Serendipity I'm sorry
let me just wrong we actually discussed
we've been discussing this in the
corridors for two days which is other
religions and Ron you had some things
that
you were going to talk about that I
would like to to Second the call for uh
extending this discussion Beyond
Christianity most of it has focused uh
not just here but I'm talking about
generally uh about Christianity and I
think because a lot of the conflict has
taken place in Christian cultures uh
unfortunately uh it is spreading around
the world into Muslim cultures uh Korea
is a hot Center for Science and religion
debate in part because there's so many
Presbyterians over there now uh but Asia
is not escaping this in the way that it
that it did uh and uh there there are
projects underway at present to explore
the relationship between science and the
world religions uh in a more systematic
way
yes please I'd like to respond to uh
to what that uh what was just said
um
I'm not sure that Confucianism is best
thought of as a religion as opposed to a
proposal for a certain kind of way of
life and it's often not thought of as a
religion I mean that's just that's not
just a peculiarity of my own way of
thinking about it
and as for I mean I agree with the
speakers certainly it would be wonderful
to extend the discussion the problem is
um we all live where we do and it's
pretty hard to get a really good handle
on what you know what's going on right
around us
um it's wonderful to go beyond that but
it's not surprising that we living here
concentrate on what we find around us
and as for Buddhism
um I mean I think she was suggesting
that not nearly all religions are
theistic that's uh that's correct but
it's not the case that Buddhism in
general isn't certain kinds of Buddhism
are and certain kinds certain kinds are
not and some are sort of sort of such
that it's just really hard to tell
whether they are or are not
and then there was also a suggestion
that only Christianity or maybe only
Christianity but and certainly not all
the other religions make exclusive truth
claims I mean if an exclusive truth
claim is just the claim is a claim like
this
that if certain proposition p is true
then any proposition incompatible with p
is false I would think everybody would
make exclusive truth claims so construed
if an exclusive truth came instead of
something like this that my religion is
true and no other religion has any truth
in it at all then I I don't think there
are many religions at all certainly not
Christianity that would make claims like
that and finally as for uh Whitehead
and the like not involving design I
guess that's right but it's not really
clear that that part of Whitehead's
philosophy is Christian Whitehead
himself didn't claim that it was and
um I don't know I don't know of any good
reason to think that in fact it is Ron
one thing that I think I will just
expand upon what he said since we're
talking about other religions I think
it's important to realize that that the
well you said it's spreading to Islam I
think you were being overly politically
correct I think I think that's one of
the big big problems with Islam has been
far less uh tolerant of Science and in
fact any kind of blasphemy for over the
last few years and so I think it's it's
certainly an area just it's it's
fundamentalist Islam is has been for a
while just as obnoxious as fundamental
of Christianity in terms of its uh
um uh fear of knowledge oh worse perhaps
and one of the problems there is that
the creationist in intelligent design
people in the Muslim Community are
pretty presenting themselves as
progressives because they're engaging
science as opposed to the to the
fundamentalist Muslims who won't even
touch the subject right the next
questioner and if excuse me but if
there's someone in particular you want
to direct the question to just let us
know and otherwise I won't ask anyone
who wants to speak can but we want to
get to every question I I'm uh Jeff
Morris a student at Yale here
um and I was struck by what Mr Krause
said earlier about how
scientists when they're doing their
experimentations for quite uh
recognizable reasons don't really spend
that much time thinking about philosophy
or theological questions
um but I was wondering for the rest of
us who have to think about things like
ethics
the uh we do every now and then too
it seems that there might be a
theoretical problem on uh basing how to
base one's ethics or can a system of
Ethics be based on naturalism and it
seems that a lot of philosophers and
theologians have come up with a negative
conclusion to that answer so I would ask
you
what is the basis for your ethics and
how would you I mean do you think that
Darwinism is a compatible ethic for
society it's a that's a very good
question I think
I think there's an important distinction
between ethics and morality okay I think
that I tried to in my lecture yesterday
I don't know if you were here talk about
the scientific ethos I think we in fact
now pretty well most science departments
that I know of have make an effort to
talk about ethics uh ethics of the
profession it's based on honesty as I
said before egalitarianism uh
non-authoritarianism uh uh complete
disclosure it's I mean there's an ethos
there that that I think is profoundly
um important and in fact
um needs no I cannot see how any appeal
to God or anything else would affect it
or would be useful I would also by the
way go beyond that and I think I I agree
certainly here with Richard Dawkins that
even if one goes beyond ethics to
morality the claim that you need
religion for Morality is specious in my
opinion and uh but certainly in the case
of Ethics professional ethics and
science
this the field progresses by being
ethical and and if if it's unethical
then it doesn't progress I think it's
just I don't see the I don't see the
need to to require a higher intelligence
in nature or any purpose to the world to
Define how you proceed with the the
process of science which is really you
know what just what scientists do they
just go out and do things they're not
supposed to lie they're not supposed to
eat they're not just to partially pick
the data uh they're not supposed to
steal other people's data and there's
lots of Ethics that that and the reason
it's done is not because of some higher
well it's because we want to proceed
toward understand the way the world
works and it doesn't work effectively if
you do those things it just doesn't work
whenever whenever you try and censor or
lie or cheat it's the science dies and
when you ever if you've ever seen
societies that require that
for political or theological or
philosophical reasons science has not
progressed if you look at genetics in
the Soviet Union at certain times and
and and so I think it's really important
to talk about ethics and you're
absolutely right that scientists I think
have only become recently more aware of
the need to discuss that probably
because of some so many unethical things
have been happening lately in science
but certainly one doesn't have to appeal
I think to to religion or or Divine
intelligence to do that
in my opinion no one wants to disagree
all right right here
I'm Mike Rhoda I'm doing a postdoc at
Harvard on science and religion
um I have a question for Dr Krauss about
uh the statement that science makes God
invisible and I
I have in mind one thing that someone
might mean by that and I don't think
it's what you mean but I wanted to check
here's what one one thing someone might
mean by saying science makes God
invisible is this science shows or
suggests that no one really has any
rational grounds to believe in God
um would you think that's true or false
wow that's an interesting statement um I
think
um
in one sense yes let me let me qualify
what I said I don't think science in
order to be compatible with religion I
think science God has to be invisible or
and let me point out this is really
important we all say science can't
disprove the existence of God but
science could prove the existence if
tomorrow the Stars realign themselves to
say I am here
for example I think you'd find many
astronomers and many physicists suddenly
saying you know maybe there's something
to be explored here and and and so I
think there's certainly many
possibilities for positive evidence for
God there aren't any that I know of but
that doesn't mean there won't ever be
but but so in that sense God has been
invisible but but getting to your other
question of of is there a rational
reason if you you mean is there any
evidentiary reason
to require the existence of God the
answer is no
I I I happened that's that I think
that's clear but
but it is a long big leap from there to
say the fact that there's no evidentiary
reason to require the existence of God
to saying there's no evidentiary there's
no reason to assume the existence of God
is is impossible I think that I think
that's that's science at this point does
not go that far and it's a huge mistake
to suggest that science requires you to
be irrational to believe there is some
purpose to the universe uh I differ from
some of my colleagues in that but I
don't see it even though I may
personally believe it
yes hi my name is Steve Stearns I'm a
professor here of evolutionary biology I
teach the Freshman evolutionary biology
I'm an atheist materialist my wife is a
believing Christian we're having our
35th very happy wedding anniversary
pretty soon
and I noticed that about six weeks into
the course I I by the way I usually
offer to have lunch with the students
after the lecture about six weeks into
the course a couple of students will ask
to go to lunch and they'll sit me down
and they'll say Okay Professor Sterns
you've been kidding around with us
you've been calling us big old bags of
molecules and you've been explaining why
we might be cooperative or altruistic
and all this other stuff but tell me
really
what is the meaning of life
that's happened to me now regularly and
so I want to know how you will answer it
well I mean you get paid for teaching
your course why do we have to answer
that
he wants to have some answers there's
I'll I'll I'll give you uh Ray
Bradbury's answer
um and there's a wonderful line in the
Martian Chronicles
um which which I'm sure you know is just
if you have red Martian Chronicles free
it's just a wonderful book
yeah it's just a wonderful book and at
one point in there
um the Martians have sort of disappeared
taken themselves out of sight as a
result of an invasion and colonization
of people from Earth and the Earth
people eventually do stupid things that
as people do to each other and pretty
much destroy the environment of Mars and
the planet Earth and everything else and
then the Martians reappear and there's
an Insight in The Narrative of the novel
that basically says that one of the
things that the Martians were puzzled
about was that the Earth creatures were
always debating the meaning of life and
the purpose of existence and people on
mars or individuals on Mars
instinctively knew that the purpose of
life was to be alive
and left it at that
um and I thought and I I think that's as
good an answer that that will satisfy
people of Faith as as well as people who
who do not have some sort of religious
faith
Ron Bob uh as somebody who once could
answer that question very precisely but
who has no answer for that now all I can
say is that I deeply sympathize with the
people it's it's a lot nicer to be able
to answer that question in some concrete
way than to have to live with the the
knowledge or lack of knowledge about
what if there is Ultimate meaning to
life which is what I live with now all
the time
no just briefly it amused me that they
would come to you I mean I understand
why but I mean if I was a student I
don't think I would come come
let me go beyond that I I think it's
it's really important that you indicate
that that you're the wrong person ask in
the sense that when people people often
ask me about that they often ask me when
I talk what my religious beliefs are in
general and I say what does it mean I I
you know as a scientist I have no
special knowledge about the meaning of
life or or the existence of God I'll
tell you my personal beliefs but it
should be irrelevant to you it's as
useful as your own personal beliefs it's
not something I have any special
expertise for so I would say I would say
as a scientist so you don't you have you
you've in principle expertise about how
the world works but that's as far as it
goes
Alvin
well I I think the I mean I sort of know
what these students what they have in
mind right I mean I think this way of
looking at the world
um deprives life of meaning I sort of
know what they mean but only sort of
what exactly what is it for a life to
have a meaning I mean that would be a
really interesting question to try to
figure this out in some detail that's
the sort of thing philosophers like to
think about I mean instead maybe of more
important things but anyway what what
would it mean to say that life has a
meaning and what would it mean to say
that it doesn't there would be some good
examples people think it would that if
life that if for example Christianity is
true or or Judaism or Islam or something
like that then life has a meaning but if
materialism is true and all there are
are atoms whirling in the void our
democratus and the like then life
doesn't have a meaning but what what
would it be for it to have a meaning
exactly I mean uh in a way if I were in
your shoes I would say
um could you explain the question
that that presumption of yours that if
we're just a bunch of molecules life
doesn't mean I think is many of us would
disagree with who tend to think we're
just a bunch of molecules I I think it's
life is a meaning you know we have this
amazing just un it's amazing that we can
think and we and we ought to and and
what we should do with life is utilize
that that that very short and amazing
ability to its maximum uh and enjoy it
oh I certainly ought to think right
yes hi yeah Rick prum in Eco college and
evolution uh we've seen a whole
perspective of mostly pessimistic views
on the future where we're headed uh
um the scientists irritated the
theologians theologians irritated the
scientists the historians and
sociologists tell us why this is pretty
intractable and might continue
um I want to you know make a positive
observation and then ask you about about
a solution
um as an ornithologist I thought that
you know the the penguin movie that was
all the rage was was amazing and then I
found out that it was the subject of a
sort of Christian creationist cult
following then I thought wow maybe maybe
we you know through our appreciation for
Penguins we'd have a lot more in common
I'd like let him sit in my Ornithology
class and learn you know a little bit
more about penguins and I think we could
come to some commonality uh
evolutionary biologists are people who
are motivated by awe and to use their
brains and as a lifelong bird watcher
I've never had to ask what the purpose
of life was you know the life list
observing Birds learning about that and
that's where I think a lot of academics
but evolutionary biologists are like my
mother-in-law is finally figured me out
but she said I get it you've got a
calling
you know and and and feel good I wasn't
going into medicine after that my
um my question is about returning to
Gould who's been mentioned several times
um and I'm wondering what's wrong really
wrong with his with his framework
because I think if you really look at
the Millennium scale of what's happened
in how we think of reality or how we
think of this experience we're having
that his solution of two magisteria one
empirical and one spiritual is is is is
not only rational but stable and the
reason why it's stable is because uh you
know you we won't have scientists
meddling over in the spiritual Realm
telling us that God does or does not
exist and you won't have a
particular theology he's getting into
science because as soon as theology gets
into science it's going to be a
Christian Theologian or a Hindu or an
Islamic Theologian and and that's going
to be very offensive to a lot of
scientists or to a lot of uh to
religions so we have a real stable
solution and Ron described the
magisteria as incomparable in one very
large and the religious one is shrinking
but if if it's really the cause of
everything in the other one of course
it's it's going to be quite large uh and
I mean a religious person I think would
experience that in faith that that that
magisterium is is magnificent and large
and so I'd like to I'd like your your
responses to that and why can't we
um try to promulgate that the trouble I
think with this is that at least most
Christians in the United States the
majority would feel like they were
giving up too much to say that religion
was no longer going to have anything to
say about the natural world when the
Bible tells them this is what happened
uh it's it may be stable and attractive
it's very prescriptive it doesn't
describe what the majority of Christians
think religion encompasses and so it's
unrealistic that's all I'm saying
subject to the instability that was
pointed out in the the quote from uh
from uh Augustine about how it's basing
a religion upon uh suppositions that are
falsifiable by going to Nature is kind
of an unstable way to build it don't
don't don't don't don't don't fight with
the facts you know I'd ask them you know
are you going to get last year's flu
shot or you're going to get this year's
where we've had a bunch of evolutionary
biologists designing the flu shot that's
going to work this year I can assure you
that neither quoting Augustine or
referring to flu shots will get you
anywhere yeah I also think it's and let
me it's nice but unrealistic in another
sense that it it it I I wish it were
that way but then the question is are
you saying there's certain questions you
can't ask for example can you not if
you're a scientist ask questions about
spirituality about the evolutionary
nature spirituality the psychological
nature of spirituality or or so at some
point it's a nice cop-out but I think
ultimately it's a cop-out
the the the this even the scientific
description of spirituality is not the
experience of spirituality and and that
magisterium is about that experience I
mean about which Rick Rick I I would I
would argue I I like I have a
superficial attraction for ghoul's
solution because it makes peace yeah it
reminds me of something that Ian Barber
once said a very distinguished scholar
of Science and religion and he said that
both oh I gotta get the word order right
here both the scientific materialist
person who says science disproves God
and the scientific creationist
um uh misuse science and religion one
makes statements about science that are
dictated by religious beliefs that's the
creationists the other one makes
seeks to make religion a part of Science
and that's the scientific materials and
both of them are wrong and I would argue
that the biggest problem I have with
Noma the non-overlapping magic theory is
it argues against the unity of knowledge
and I think ultimately knowledge ought
to be won in one sense or another and I
I want to quickly address the first
thing you said about all these
pessimistic views up here
um and I've written about this brown is
a small enough school this one come as a
shock at Yale but if I was at Michigan
State it would Brown is small enough
that I actually know people in other
departments okay
um and I remember once not very long ago
having a whole bunch of people over
dinner in our house and we drank a lot
of wine and as a result of that we
started to talk about really stupid
things and one of the stupid things was
if you could live anytime in history and
be alive what time would you pick okay
so this went around the table and there
was a philosopher there and the
philosopher said no offense Alvin that
the most interesting time to be alive
would have been ancient Greece during
the academy with Plato and Aristotle and
so forth and since then philosophy
straight downhill
um my wife
my wife who was an artist said she
wanted to live in Paris in the 1880s
during the birth of the impressionist
movement because she thought that was
the single most creative period and
creative place in art and so forth and
so on Gordon Wood is a very
distinguished scholar of the American
Revolution said who's worked on the
revolution his whole life he would have
liked to live during the revolution so
he could write about it from director is
and then all of a sudden people realize
that their four four scientists in the
room and none of us had said a thing and
finally they said okay why don't you
guys speak up and we all started to look
at each other and we smiled and we
started to giggle and we realized we all
had the same answer which is for anyone
involved in science the most exciting
time in human history to be alive is now
and I consider that to be profoundly
optimistic notion maybe tomorrow I'd say
not now but
I would always like to be alive tomorrow
because we we do have other people I'd
like to respond too to your question
about Gould I think um I I don't I don't
see much much Merit in it at all I mean
basically it's not just that he says
we'll had the religionists should hand
over the whole natural world to uh to
the scientists what he really says is
there are two kinds of two kinds of
propositions in the world factual
propositions and normative or evaluative
propositions religion deals with a
former science deals with a latter
well this seems to me to be completely
wrong I mean any religions that I know
of or at least the vast majority of
religions make very impressive factual
claims for example Christianity says in
Buddhism I mean Christianity uh the
other abrahamic religions Islam and
Judaism there is this great being
omnipotent omniscient and holy good who
created the whole world and
um we owe him allegiance to the like of
that I mean that's an enormous factual
statement it's about as big a factual
statement as you want to cross so if you
really take what he says seriously not
even things like that would I mean even
things like that would be outside the
pale of religion religion could only do
with values It could only say what's
good and what's bad and how people ought
to live and this and that but I mean
that seems to me to be uh to be just
totally unrealistic it would completely
eviscerate any kind of religion and as a
matter of fact ghoul tries to enlist the
pope on his side of all people and there
if you take a careful look at what he
says it seems I mean he just he just
wildly Off the Mark the pope wouldn't
believe that for a minute and I'm with a
pope despite being a calvinist
History of Science
um given the degree of scientific
illiteracy that we're dealing with with
this whole debate and given that um
at least at the high school and an early
college level
creationists and intelligent design
supporters
tend to have actually a better
understanding of the relevant science
than sort of
the general that age population
might it be a boon for science in the
long run the success the current
successes of intelligent design either
here or in
for example Islamic countries that
have so much resistance to science
altogether
I I wouldn't go so far as to say it's
it's a boon I would go so far as to say
it's a great opportunity and I also
um the the the Islamic critics of
evolution who include a Turkish writer
named who writes under the pen name of
Haroon yaha have actually asked this
young Islamic and one of the fun things
about this is and I got a kick out of
this is that her and Yahoo presents
you'll love this presents Evolution as a
Christian plot to subvert the morals of
Islamic youth so think about Evolution
as a Christian plot it's just delightful
I'd love to think about that
um but the interesting thing is as was
pointed out that her and yaha actually
tells Islamic youth to consider science
and he says science suppose the Quran
and so forth and so on but from my point
of view especially considering the fact
that the Islamic World in a way LED in
science through about the 14th or 15th
century and has essentially abandoned it
in modern times anything that gets the
Islamic World seriously talking about
science is probably a good thing and as
I said I don't think it's the
controversy has been a boon to science
but I think it's it's a moment of great
opportunity and I think such moments are
not to be wasted well I would again I
think you're being a little too
optimistic I agree with you I mean every
problem is an opportunity a global
warming presents us a great opportunity
to become more energy efficient and but
I wish we didn't have to confront the
huge problem that we're about going to
have to front and in this case it would
be I think there might be much more
productive ways to talk about The Wonder
of Nature and get people excited about
the world than having to do it in a
negative way and to combat
a fault sort of a misunderstanding
it's much better it seems to me to be
positive than negative and so you're
right it's an opportunity but I think
it's to be a lot better opportunities
than I wish I had
um I want to try to bring this in on
time which we're going to miss a little
so could I ask you both to ask your
questions and then and then people here
can address them both or either sure
sure my name is Aaron Mertz I'm a first
year graduate student in the department
of physics here at Yale and I must admit
I'm a little disheartened by the number
of by the small number of students in
the audience here today and my questions
to professors Krauss and Miller
um what can or at what point in their
careers could scientists whether
aspiring or established begin to engage
these issues especially as related to
the public understanding of Science and
what can they do
okay that's a good question and if I
just the other question then we'll thank
you David newhauser University of Oxford
I have two quick questions for both uh
both for professors uh Miller and
plantinga
um there's been a lot of talk about the
limits of science but I wonder if we
could talk a little bit more about the
limits of Theology and to take the
discourse onto another level I was
um somewhat concerned about the the
nature of divine action and causality
that was envisioned in in both of your
talks and I'd like you to expand upon
that first Professor plantinger I I was
concerned that
um you're you're talking about God
guiding
um the process of uh of evolution at
points might imply that God's activity
is a cause which might be on the same
level with a natural cause but and I'm
concerned that this might buy into the
antagonism between science and religion
that the
um the antagonists in this debate
have been promulgating and and uh
Professor Miller I was wondering if you
envision at points in your lecture that
science and religion might ask different
sorts of questions I wonder whether you
think that science is theologically
relevant which is to say do you think
that
um objective inquiry into the natural
world can tell us things about God
let's see let me answer yours first
because then we can move over it to that
table to answer the both questions
um so your question
uh it's a really good question and I I
think that uh but my advice to Young
scientists especially if they're good is
to do science uh that's really that's
where you're gonna have if you have a
talent and ability and an interest and
excitement you should be doing that to
the greatest extent you can but of
course we're if you have and I suspect
you do from the way you ask the question
uh you have to be true to your own
interests and we are citizens and it's
extremely important for those scientists
and I don't think every scientist needs
to do this I don't think everyone
scientists should spend their time doing
some of the things that I do for example
but if it's if it's within inside inside
you you have a great opportunity as you
do science to to have an impact on
society as a citizen and so that will
continue to grow but but I really think
that young scientists should should to
be doing the best thing you can do is is
provide new knowledge about the world
and then as you do it to disseminate it
and so uh it will one will come with the
other but I think it's really important
that um that you you take whatever
opportunities you have and they'll grow
you don't have to create them you don't
have to spend all of your time trying to
to you know write articles at newspapers
or whatever but they'll grow with time
but uh but if your love is science you
should be doing science yeah I want to
concur completely with what Lawrence
just said in terms of
um establish your career uh move into
science it's the single most important
thing that anybody can do and while
you're doing it share your excitement
enthusiasm about science with your
roommates your friends other people let
them know that science science is a draw
um you also started off by observing
that there are very few students here
um I want to make an observation
scheduling
um I spoke last week at the University
of Kansas on the same topic
650 people came almost all of them
students why was that is is the student
body at Kansas so much more interested
in science than student body at Yale
what maybe so but I think the critical
thing was talk was 7 30 in the evening
people didn't have to go to class that's
that's the big thing
and then the two of you if you could
take right
this about guiding
now um
so what I was really saying was not that
I wasn't proposing as a matter of fact
God does guide this evolutionary course
I say all I was saying so in my talk
actually was this is perfectly possible
this could happen Christians are
committed to thinking that God in a very
broad sense of guides guides The
evolutionary process where that very
broad sense would include his setting up
uh his setting up in advance certain
kinds of mechanisms that he knows will
issue in the sorts of results he wants
but whether this involves micromanaging
um thumb on the scale as Margaret was
saying on the one hand or he's just
arranging everything in advance so it's
going to turn out the way he wants on
the other hand that's a different
question now as to whether say
Christians are committed I think to one
or the other of these two ways of
looking at it whether or not and not
just Christians other theists you
suggest that might exacerbate the debate
or exacerbate the problem
well I don't see why I mean
Christians and others have a right to
figure out what they want to think you
know and if that's what um if that
what's is that what's what's uh what
follows from theism and you're a theist
um I don't think you have to worry that
other people are going to disagree maybe
some other people will disagree but why
don't you have a right to think it you
know just as a naturalist has got a
right to think he's a naturalist and to
think naturalism is true so I'm not sure
the fact that some other people would
disagree and hits there might be a some
kind of exacerbated debate I I'm not
sure that's really relevant I was
actually wondering whether it's a
confusion of the character of religious
Faith whether that's a confusion to
confuse Divine activity with natural
causation or to say that the same sort
of thing oh yeah you did right so um
so
you could think of God as acting in two
different ways one way is acting
directly he himself directly does
something and if there are other
creatures that act then from a theistic
point of view God must have created
something or other directly maybe he
created one thing which created another
which created another and so on but he
has to have created something directly
on the other hand God could act
indirectly by creating creatures who do
certain things as far as I can see there
is no reason in the world to think that
God couldn't act in both ways in his
world it's not as if if he did something
directly he would be confusing I mean
it's not as if thinking that would be
confusing god with a creature seems to
me I mean why can't God as a
non-creature as a Creator act both ways
in fact he's got to act the direct way
at some point if there are to be any
actions of the indirectly
I I suppose just just to bring it back
to Professor Miller that that raises the
second question which is would such
action be identifiable which is also to
ask is natural science theologically
relevant right I I think natural science
is theologically relevant because it
tells us about the world which atheists
believes God has created and informing
us about the nature that world is
theologically relevant and is important
um uh unfortunately and this is probably
because I'm not a calvinist
um I'm going to reject both of the ways
in which Dr planting I just said God
might work and I wrote down I hope I got
them right either by he said Christians
are either committed to a god that
guides The evolutionary process or
arranges thing in things in advance so
he knows how it's going to come out
both of those actions deny creation a
certain degree of Independence in terms
of things are fixed the game is rigged
it's going to come out in a particular
way and I think the science that has
emerged in the last hundred years
particularly in physics has shown that
the behavior of the natural world is
profoundly indeterminate at its most
basic level not completely stochastic
and random enchants but but but unable
to be predicted in detail and that's an
extremely important theological point
which I think is relevant to theology if
you take a theological view of nature as
God's creation then it's perfectly
obvious that that Divine being has built
in a kind of Independence to the world
so that things could not have been
directly arranged in advance and I would
argue the central point of of of
Christian theology is that we have
Independence that we have free will that
we are to a degree independent of the
Creator and one of the things that
Aquinas said basically is that a world
that was devoid of chance of things
happening on their own could never be
truly independent of its creator and
therefore I think the findings of modern
science in this respect show that
Independence directly now if you don't
believe in God you figure okay that's
the way the world is but if you do
believe in God what it tells you is that
the creation has a degree of
independence from the Creator that makes
moral choice possible that makes your
actions for the future relevant in the
sense that the future is not rigged and
advanced is not micromanaged by God but
you're going to have something to do
with it and that point of individual
personal responsibility for what's going
to happen to the world I would argue is
a point on which people of faith and
people who are atheist and agnostic can
agree which is to say what happens in
this world now in the choices we make
are relevant and are important and are
worth thinking about could I say make a
very brief rejoinder yeah yeah please um
of course I I agree wholeheartedly with
Ken about the importance of moral choice
and about human beings being independent
of God in the sense that God creates
them and then allows them to make
certain choices and make them freely
absolutely I certainly concur with that
uh where I disagree with them is where I
think he and you'll excuse me makes a
certain confusion I mean it's it's one
thing to say that um I can act freely
it's quite another thing to say that God
won't can't know in advance uh what I'm
in fact going to do the fact that I will
in a few minutes I will presumably
freely walk out either that door or this
door I would say there's a truth about
which one I will walk out of the fact
that there is a truth about that and
that God in fact knows that truth
doesn't seem to me for a minute to
compromise my freedom in going the one
way rather than the other it's just that
he knows what I will freely do
poof and on that Cosmic thought I'm
going to end this thank you all very
much thank the organizers the Terry
Lecter and our panelists thank you